well more now on the breaking news this
morning that the foreign secretary
dominic raab
has said that families of u.s personnel
serving at raf crowton
in northamptonshire will no longer have
immunity from criminal prosecution
this follows a meeting with the parents
of harry dunn who was killed in the
collision outside the base
with a car driven by a former cia
officer and seculars
while joining us now is harry's mother
charlotte charles
and the spokesperson and lawyer for the
family
rad sega thank you very much indeed
uh for being with us uh first of all
this a new agreement does it only apply
to people working at raf crowton
yes that's been confirmed adam that that
these arrangements
um have only applied um to croton but
look and as you say we're absolutely
thrilled
um what what um the parents set out to
do
other than of course bringing out
sakura's back is to make sure
that this will never happen again and
that is what they've achieved today
it's a huge development of unprecedented
that you you know you ever secure these
sort of free waivers but
um look the absolute you know
fundamental thing is
um here we are in july 2020
with the americans having agreed that
nobody like crap
now has immunity uh what's good now
is must have been good at last august
when harry was killed
and they absolutely now have to send her
back
and and as uh harry's mother how do you
feel today
i feel really proud of ourselves as us
for parents we've
campaigned so very very hard to make
sure that another
family doesn't get treated the way we
have been
so we're we're really pleased it's a
huge step forward
but we're only halfway there you know
this campaign will never go away until
we've made sure that ansel kuhler is
brought back to the uk
but um we are we are proud of our
achievements and
harry would be really proud of us too
yeah indeed but it's not retrospective
is it
so at this stage there's no particular
reason or guarantee that ann seculars
will actually come back
to face justice in this country and
that's right adam and you know the
united states as the
as the sending state it's their decision
um and if they choose not to we can't go
and kidnap her
but morally illegally this is
indefensible they are not behaving in
accordance with
international norms particularly having
um
agreed uh to this um free waiver today
so we now call on the foreign secretary
and the british government
to make it absolutely clear that
panzerkulas has to come back
and if she doesn't what the consequences
are going to
be and just was one example they
suspended the extradition treaty
with hump with hong kong you know if if
the americans are not going to play ball
with extra division
between the uk and the us then then i've
asked
we had a meeting with dominic rob this
morning and i've asked him to consider a
range of options
which he could take to bring the uh the
americans back into
uh you know the international forum
and and specifically will you campaign
for
uh this change in in the way that uh
diplomatic immunity is treated to be
expanded beyond
uh the raf base itself to all american
diplomatic personnel
look it's our it's our position adam
that nobody
is above the law and of course that's
what the vietnam convention
actually says that you should you should
even if you are a diplomat
you should stay and abide by the laws of
your host country
and uh that is britain's position abroad
it waves immunity every single time
um but you know they have
they have to be absolutely clear whoever
they are that nobody is above the law
any diplomat in this country has to stay
in the consequences of their actions
none of this though is is going to bring
sadly is going to bring harry back is it
no it's not going to bring him back
and we have to live with that pain every
day so believe we
believe me we know he's gone and we know
that everything we're doing isn't going
to bring
our precious boy back but
when we lost him that promise i made to
him to make sure justice was done
is still burns as strong as ever and the
determination that we as
a family have to get ann sukunis back
will never waver
um so yeah you're right it won't bring
him back
but it sure as hell will make sure
that no other family particularly in
this area at the moment
will ever suffer the way we have um
but you are right to say that we will
still be campaigning to make sure that
that does include the other bases in the
country
we just have to start to understand an
awful lot more what their agreements are
and and what are your feelings towards
answer coolest because i i think you'd
probably accept that this was
a dreadful accident it wasn't something
she wanted
to do at all
it's not an accident because it could
have been prevented you know if she'd
have driven on the correct side of the
road then it wouldn't have happened so
we don't use the word accident
um i don't feel any hate towards anybody
in this campaign you know that's that's
not what we're about
but i do feel extremely strongly that
she needs to come back
and face the justice system you know any
one of us would have to do it
um she needs to do the same as well you
know
get over here get it over and done with
um we don't
even we don't even care what the cps
would hand down what thoughts would hand
down to her
you know it's not about the the
punishment or the sentencing
it's clearly just for us like we've said
from
the start it's just about doing the
right thing
it really is that simple to us and
i would expect any member of my family
to have to do the same
if she was on the 11 foot and i would
certainly be doing it myself
so i don't see that she should be any
different